hello there internet i'm john oliver
host of last week tonight we're off this
week but i wanted to briefly come back
to talk to you about something important
and that is rules think of them as the
bones of a well-functioning society
which i guess makes common sense and
good judgment the blood manners the skin
fortitude the heart and this show
these nerds
specifically though
i want to talk about rules as they apply
to 1997's airbud a movie that is quietly
about grief but it's loudly about a dog
playing basketball if you've never seen
it i'm going to show you the the moment
that our hero josh realizes that his dog
has an unexpected talent it's a moment
when josh is very sad and then this
happens
fine
you can play
yeah so
the dog scores a basket grin stupidly
and in that moment josh's world changes
and we as an audience are set for a wild
ride the
quickest possible explanation of what
happens in air bud is it is the story of
a dog playing basketball on a team full
of children who then wins state the
slightly longer version is that a kid
named josh's father dies and he tries to
fill that void with a dog the movie
generally glides past this point but the
fundamental issue here is that a kid who
doesn't have a father tries to replace
him with a golden retriever who happens
to be good at basketball not that good
though to be honest he can't dribble or
rebound or box out he's not really a
playmaker and has little to no
basketball iq really he's just quite
good at shooting and don't worry i'm not
going to ruin 1997's air bud for you if
if i wanted to do that i'd say either
that the dog who played him is
definitely dead by now or
or that it must have been nice to make
content before 9 11. that's what i'd say
i'd say one of those things dogs die and
9 11 will happen if you haven't seen
earbuds then you almost definitely
haven't seen the many sequels and
spin-offs
that have spawned and while we don't
have time to get into the plots of all
of them i do need you to see just how
far the franchise ended up straying from
its simple dog play sports
rings routes given us some epic power
just think of the good we can do it
yeah but they have superpowers now uh
point a is a movie where a dog is kind
of okay at basketball point z is a movie
where that same dog's children are the
avengers but dogs now
we don't actually have time to get into
the zendaya vehicle super buddies
because again i need to talk about the
original and i know what you're thinking
you're thinking he must get paid extra
to do these web exclusives
i don't and and if you're thinking well
okay but there must be something in his
contract that says he has to produce a
certain number of content units per
season there isn't but i will say i do
appreciate your use of the phrase
content units unlike it
um that is how i think about this show
i'm a material generator who distributes
content units designed to occupy your
time between now and death but i'm not
i'm not talking about earbuds because i
have to
i'm doing it because i want to
now even if you are not an airbud
superfan you are probably familiar with
the oft-cited line about basketball
rules that has been repeated and
parodied for years now
you're checking your
but you won't find anything in there
that says a dog can't play he's right
ain't no rule said the dog can't play
basketball
yes ain't no rule says a dog can't play
basketball
and it's both stupid and weirdly true
there is
still literally no rule on the books
preventing a dog from playing basketball
anyway my main concern is that this is a
fundamentally flawed premise i know
there's no rule that says a dog can't
play basketball i know that i went to
oxford probably but it's
definitely unfair to introduce a new
player and suddenly claim he's a
registered member of the team let alone
when a state championship is on the line
sorry but when kevin durant
goes down with an injury in a crucial
game the nets don't get to just bring in
a random unsigned untested additional
player there are no surprise guests in
basketball isn't that right mr kevin
durant
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now
[Applause]
obviously we didn't get kevin durant for
this bit it's the playoffs right now
plus this is a web exclusive about
airbud
it would have been insulting of us to
even ask but look that crucial point
there isn't a rule preventing the dog
from playing basketball is the central
conceit of the film but it doesn't
really address the key question which is
should
the dog play basketball and set aside a
moment the morality or the ethics at
play here let's talk purely about air
buds basketball production
here's what we know about airbud or
buddy which is his given name based on
the game tape that is available to us
two steals
five assists
two free throws
and four field goals that is it
that is his entire box score now i'm not
saying that's bad no one's saying that's
bad
but is that dog an asset to the
fernfield timberwolves the showtime
timberwolves i'd submit that he's not
and it's honestly shocking to me that a
coach so focused on teamwork her
operation and ball movement would allow
such a distraction to dominate the
team's narrative again if buddy was
doing numbers now if he's putting up 30
to 40 points a night we're having a very
different conversation right now
but he's not is he
i repeat
four field goals
and apart from the steals he's a
complete liability on defense but
there's an even bigger question when it
comes to should airbud be playing
basketball and that is that airbud
crucially is not josh's dog
right
he belongs to norm snively
josh the boy with the dead dad remember
found him but buddy
was snively's dog he had the paperwork
to prove it and everything
before buddy discovered basketball
snively included him as part of his act
as a birthday party clown we see this at
the start of the film with snively
arriving at a birthday party around the
same time it's revealed that the film
was produced by harvey weinstein
yeah
that's how the movie begins
anyway
we then see snively utterly bombing in
front of the kids at the party at which
point buddy tries to salvage the act by
catching some balls in his mouth
[Applause]
yeah pretty impressive right
everyone had fun
and a
not terrible argument could be made that
snively was the one who gave buddy the
fundamental training that resulted in
him being able to play basketball in the
first place stein he gets a lot of [ __ ]
in this film because he's an abusive
alcoholic party clown who explicitly
hates children and birthdays but you
cannot ignore
that he is also the kind of person who
can diligently and patiently train a dog
to perform party tricks that's not
nothing is it training dogs is hard and
snively put the work in yet
snively's made to suffer because he lost
the dog who was then retrieved by josh
the kid whose dad ate it off camera
before the movie started
snively even successfully retrieves
buddy in the middle of the film but josh
then sneaks into snipes in his yard and
steals buddy back and if he's saying
john if you say john hang on now if you
say john just stop listen to me snively
was an alcoholic failed birthday party
clown who wasn't properly taken care of
buddy and even though yes he had the
paperwork documenting proper providence
of the dog it was obviously receiving
much better care through josh and his
family i hear your point i really do
it's the movies point isn't it the movie
fed you that point and no disrespect you
ate it up uncritically
because for those who don't know let me
tell you how airbud ends because it's
pretty nuts
this movie this movie about a kid who
becomes obsessed with a stolen
basketball dog after his
dad bites it off screen insanely does
not actually end with a dramatic
basketball moment you would think
knowing everything we know about movies
that it would end with air bud and the
timberwolves winning state and then cut
into credits but you'd be wrong dead
wrong i'm talking josh's dad dead wrong
instead
instead snovely attempts to regain
ownership of buddy even contacting a
judge the judge in his wisdom decides
two things one he will ultimately only
make a ruling on this case outside on
the lawn which
sure i'm not getting into that but two
on the subject of lawful dog ownership
he is convinced to let the dog decide so
paperwork be damned buddy the dog
will decide who he wants to live with
and whoever he chooses will henceforth
be his legal permanent owner now
predictably buddy chooses the boy who
has given him nothing but affection and
freedom snively much less predictably is
physically carried off by several cops
to jail
which is ridiculous
the legal system does not normally work
that fast the fact that i believe one of
the movies producers can attest to first
hand
look
here is
the most
reasonable argument i've heard in
defense of josh's ownership of buddy
josh is good
snively is bad
therefore josh deserves the dog okay
but what do we mean when we say that
right deserves i'm not trying to be
controversial here i'm just performing a
logical extraction of moral intention
based on following the breadcrumbs left
by 1997's airbud
but
loves to position itself as a
celebration of rules there ain't no rule
that says a dog can't play basketball
but as long as we're all pretending that
rules or the absence of them are the
most important thing in the world how is
it that there are rules about dog
ownership
that it seems air but the film is so
keen for you to forget here's what i'm
really trying to say here rules either
matter or they don't and if you are
going to try and throw the spirit
of the law in my face oh [ __ ] you let's
definitely talk about that because
suddenly it's subjective isn't it and
then things get much muddier here is
here's a thought exercise for you let's
tweak some variables shall we let's say
let's say the disease snively suffers
from isn't alcoholism it's
diabetes let's say snively has diabetes
now
should that count against him
as a dog owner snively shouldn't have
body he's an unsuccessful party clown
with diabetes
is that a good argument do you like how
that sounds
here's another variable let's say
instead of being good at basketball he
absolutely sucks at it
now now do we now care where buddy ends
up if he's a dog who's bad at basketball
where's the line here
does buddy only deserve a better home if
he's good at basketball and if the
answer to that is yes what does that say
about us as a society
i want to be absolutely clear here i'm
not mad that the timberwolves won state
as a result of buddy's middling
performance though not to hammer at the
point
four field goals
i'm also not mad that josh got buddy
based on a court ruling that took place
outdoors with a judge in an office chair
i'm not even mad the buddy's real legal
owner not only lost his dog but remember
got physically carted off by police
in one of the most flagrant examples of
america's fetish for castle solutions
ever committed to film
i just want to understand the rules
the rules that are supposed to be so
foundationally important to the air bud
story and if you're thinking john come
on enough
enough now
josh lost his dad
have a heart guys
i hear you
i do that's my point he's reacting from
an emotional place does he want buddy
or is he like i said 45 minutes ago just
trying to fill the void
left by his father and if so why on
earth are we putting the care and safety
of a hit dog
in the hands of a grieving child because
there ain't no rule against it listen to
yourself
now
is this the worst thing to happen to
movies no
no it isn't the worst thing to happen to
movies is kissing there's too much
kissing in movies no one likes the sound
of it and no one likes mouths the
pandemic was actually great for two
reasons it briefly shut down movies and
everyone had to wear masks in both cases
everyone saw fewer mouths and we were
all happier for it i just find it
fascinating that a movie the sole
premise of which hinges on a strict
adherence to rules
chooses to discard them so quickly on
such a whim
that's all
you're probably thinking right now wait
really that is all
there is no twist here oh why would you
waste so much of your time and ours
on a web exclusive that's quietly about
air bud but loudly about nothing i'll
tell you why
i'll tell you specifically why because
there ain't no rule against it
thank you so much for watching i have no
idea why you did we're back on may 1st
goodbye
you